أنت لم تمتلك ما فعلته بعد ،
لكنك ما زلت تعتقد بطريقة ما أنك على حق في
أنك طبيب
يحق لك ألا تستمع إليه
وبعد ذلك قمت بالعلاج ، فلن
أرسل كلابي إليك سيدي لك  لقد خرجت
من الصفحة هنا فيما يتعلق بما أفعله ، فإن
صفحتي لا تزيد عن 200 عام يا سيدي
، أعطي لك 175 عامًا ، أي 2100
شهر ،
لقد وجدت للتو ولدت أصمًا لأنك سيدي
لا تستحق أن تمشي خارج
السجن  مرة أخرى ، لا يمكنك
إعادة براءتهم إلى شبابهم ،
لا يمكنك إعادة الأب إلى حياته
لواحدة من ضحاياك حياتها عندما
أخذتها ، أجد أنك لا تفهم
أنك تشكل خطرًا عليك  تظل خطرًا ،
لقد علمت أن لديك مشكلة منذ
صغر سنك حتى قبل أن تصبح طبيبة ، كان من
الممكن أن تأخذ نفسك بعيدًا عن
الإغراء ولم تكن كلماتك في
الأيام العديدة
الماضية لها تأثير عاطفي كبير
على نفسي وهزتني  في صميمي
، أدركوا أيضًا أن ما أشعر به
يتضاءل بالمقارنة  لصدمة الألم
والدمار العاطفي ،
عمق واتساع مدى آسفي
لما حدث ، اعتذار مقبول
يا سيدي ، تحتاج إلى إنهاء الميكروفون أو
لا يمكنهم سماع
اعتذار مقبول لكم جميعًا ، من المستحيل أن
أكتب وأنقل.  سيحمل كلامك
معي لبقية أشيائي